en este vídeo veremos algunas
estrategias para restar decimales que
contengan centésimos por ejemplo si
tengo 0 puntos 69 o 69 centésimos y a
esto le tengo que restar 0.34 o 34
centésimas cuál va a ser el resultado
pausa este vídeo y trata de resolverlo
hay muchas maneras de pensar en esto una
de ellas es que aquí tenemos 69
centésimos y a esto le vamos a restar 34
centésimos y cuando a 69 le restas algo
en este caso 69 centésimos le restamos
34 centésimos con cuánto me voy a quedar
bueno cuánto es 69 menos 34 94 es igual
a 5 y 60 menos 30 es igual a 30 así que
me quedan 35 centésimos que puede
escribir como 0.35
ahora otra manera en que puedo pensar en
esto es que puedo separar los décimos y
los centésimos así que puedo ver esto
como seis décimos menos tres décimos
seis décimos menos tres décimos más
nueve centésimos menos cuatro céntimos
más nueve centésimos menos cuatro
céntimos y vamos a obtener el mismo
resultado a seis décimos le quitó tres
décimos y esto me va a dar como
resultado tres décimos que puede
escribir como 0.3 a esto le tengo que
sumar nueve centésimas menos cuatro
centésimas que es cinco centésimos y que
puedo escribir como 0.05
entonces tres décimos más cinco
centésimos es igual a 35 centésimos que
podemos escribir como 3 decimos el 13 en
la posición de los décimos y 5
centésimos esto es 35 centésimos como
ven hay varias maneras de restar
centésimos
hagamos otro ejemplo este probablemente
sea un poco más sencillo 343 centésimos
menos 2 cuál es el resultado pausa el
vídeo y trata de resolver lo bueno que
puede resultar sencillo pensar que esto
es igual a 3 más 43 centésimos menos 2
y si miramos los enteros podemos ver que
tenemos 3 enteros a los que debemos
restar 2 así que nos va a quedar un
entero y seguimos teniendo estos 43
centésimos
entonces sumamos 43 centésimos y el
resultado va a ser igual a 1 y 43
centésimos o lo podemos escribir como
1.43 este ejemplo tal vez fue muy fácil
ahora tratemos de combinar las ideas de
estos dos últimos ejemplos y hagamos uno
un poco más difícil digamos que queremos
saber cuánto es 65 puntos 79 menos 40 y
2.58 pausa en el vídeo y traten de saber
cuál es el resultado hay muchas maneras
de hacer esto podríamos separar los
números enteros 65 - 42 65 menos 42 y
ahora piensen en los centésimos más 79
centésimos + 79 centésimos
- 58 centésimas menos 58 centésimas y lo
voy a escribir con palabras para
reforzarlo
estos son 79 de algo 79 centésimos
podríamos decir siete décimos y nueve
centésimas pero es lo mismo que 79
centésimos
y estos son 58 centésimos y ahora 65 42
5-12 es igual a 3 en la posición de las
unidades y 6 menos 4 es igual a 2
entonces tengo 23 más
79 centésimos menos 58 centésimos 70
menos 50 es igual a 20 y 9 menos 8 es
igual a 1 así que esto es igual a 21
centésimos que podemos escribir como
0.21
y para terminar tenemos 23 y 21
centésimas esta es una manera de abordar
el problema hay múltiples formas para
resolver problemas de restas como este